let's take one more call let's go to
victoria in austin texas victoria what's
happening
hey john how are you so good how are you
i'm doing great thanks so much for
taking my call today uh you bet thanks
for calling how can i help
so i my dad
was bike or diagnosed with bipolar 2
a few years ago okay and i'm struggling
with
how to have a boundaries conversation
with him
what type of boundaries well
um i guess we have kind of a
non-traditional you know relationship um
he was very
uh verbally and emotionally abusive with
me growing up
um and you know i've as i've gotten
older i've kind of noticed it more and
more how kind of on
not normal it is um
and so you know just a lot of times i
get pressure from my grandparents to
spend time with him or see him
even though i can clearly feel that it's
uncomfortable
um i mean it gets the point where my
anxiety is so heightened that i mean i
don't sleep for a couple days
if i interact with them at all um you
know because he is
bipolar you know that honestly that
diagnosis gave our family a lot of
answers as to why
he is the way that he is you know
growing up he was always
a pretty manic um he would
you know everybody walks on eggshells
around him he's
you never know what you're going to get
for the most part you know it was
it was usually going to be anger and
that was kind of just how it was that's
that was the normal
you know that's just kind of what i grew
up around
so you know as like i said i've gotten
older i've noticed that
you know i i'm very aware now of the
fact that
i've correlated seeing him with this
heightened anxiety with you know not
sleeping
really just critically over analyzing
everything you know
when i go home to visit like okay how do
i tell them i'm here or
do i have to tell them i'm here it's
just this whole thing
and i really just want to kind of take
control of the situation
and figure out how to say you know what
you know i'm an adult now
if i don't want to see you i don't want
to see you and you got to be okay with
that but i think
that kind of the little girl in me still
has a huge amount of fear
around him and kind of that how's he
gonna react or it
you know he's probably gonna get mad so
maybe i shouldn't have this conversation
that kind of thing
so kirsten i'm high-fiving you
i am double high-fiving you from
nashville to texas
oh sorry you're not kissing your
victoria let me read you that one again
sorry
victoria you still there
yeah i'm here all right victoria i am
high-fiving you
from nashville to texas you are an
absolute rock star
i i every time
a child turns again we we had this
earlier with clinton every time a child
turns and stares down childhood trauma
and says no more
i just want a high five that's not going
to be easy but i don't high five
so here's the deal yeah very quickly
boundaries are for you
not for him right your boundaries are
about
your safety your boundaries are about
your relationships
your joy your ability to function in and
out of every day
he doesn't get a vote he doesn't get an
influence
and he doesn't he doesn't get taken into
account when you are deciding
the boundaries for you and your family
period
now bipolar to bipolar one
any diagnostic is a context
not an excuse right okay
he had bipolar too so be it
he doesn't get to verbally abuse you
yeah he had bipolar too he doesn't get
to
fill your home with rage and pain
and not show you connection and not show
you love
and traumatize you and send you off
careening
through a lifetime of trying to find
connection through all sorts of
different ways
it's a context not an excuse
okay yeah well and and to throw a wrench
into everything
i think that he's kind of sensed that
you know i'm
i'm pushing further and further away and
you know for a while it was like
he you know he'll call me and just
seeing his name on my phone
like my stomach drops and yeah but but
listen victoria victoria
it doesn't matter what he senses
you're still letting him have power over
you
yeah take that brick out backpack
completely what i was gonna say
is that he he senses me kind of getting
my distance
and so he's like hey guess what uh
grandma and grandpa and i are gonna come
up to visit you
and tell them this isn't a good weekend
you know why because you get to decide
you absolutely get to decide that and it
may be a really awkward trip one day
when they come and you don't see them
and that will be a choice that those
three adults made
not you
right okay you no longer have to carry
that burden
what you do have to do is draw really
firm boundaries
and be very clear about them the hard
part about drawing boundaries
where you're drawing them is they tend
to be kind of flexible
kind of loose kind of back and forth
and it sends mixed messages to people it
makes it very challenging to know where
your boundaries are going to truly be so
you've got to take some time and say
i will not see him other than these
times
when my grandparents tell me they give
me the guilt trip and they give me
i will follow up with this statement
and i will practice letting it go i will
block his number if i have to i'll pull
out my cell phone and delete it
because i get to do that because i'm a
grown-up
and it might be for a few months it
might be for a season
it might be forever but you get to draw
that boundary
not him and they call and say guess what
we've been missing you so we're all
coming up to visit
that's when they're testing how how hard
how strong is that fence going to hold
and that's when you say hey guys i'm not
going to be here or
i'm not going to be available this
weekend well we're coming anyway that's
great but i'm not going to be able to
see you
yeah because i in in no under no
circumstances do i want him in my home
especially alone
there you go right there you go and
that's your decision and it's going to
be hard again
i can say this over and over and over
it's going to be hard it really is
but it's a choice you get to make and so
be clear
make sure everybody knows for somebody
with bipolar
something that's really helpful is a
letter because they can
hold it and they can go back to it
and they can go back to it in a in a
hypomanic state they can go back for
bipolar 2 folks they can go back to it
when they are
low they can go back to it when they are
flying through life and functioning
great
but that way it's not a one-time
conversation that gets filtered
and gets waved through it's something
they can hold and see
it might be something for your
grandparents if they can have a
conversation with you if they need it in
writing too
great so be it but it's going to be
about you saying here's my boundaries
this is the way it's going to be i'm in
control of my
adult life and here's where i'm headed
with or without you and i'm
so proud of you for making that decision
mental health diagnosis i'll say it
again i'll say it again i'll say it
again are context and not an excuse
and your boundaries are yours not theirs
good for you
good for you